okay we all for people who are joining
this livestream this is another episode
in the process of designing our trees
functionality for wolfing language and
I'm somewhat optimistic that this is
that we are reaching the end of this
design process for this area of
functionality which will be exciting and
I gather that a bunch of stuff is
implemented in our prototype build so
should I open this notebook in the
prototype build do you think what do you
think so
perhaps we can have a look at the guide
page just called treating you you had a
guide page called trees so we didn't do
I opened it in the prototype build then
we had a crease page before it was just
the beginning okay
but for this project right it wasn't a
trees page from the ancient from like 20
years ago or something I think it was
for the same one but okay here we first
wanted to start listing the
functionality okay by the way a
completely random thing that I recently
learnt our XML importer okay which is a
separate binary apparently is our last
straggling 32-bit binary on the Mac I
don't know whether you guys have
anything to do with the XML but the tree
generation from XML or anybody thinks
they know anything about that that's
actually one of two cuz there's also
QuickTime but I don't think that's
really relevant to this meaning okay
fine okay how do I make a tree here so
that I'm okay so perhaps if you go to
the respirator of tournament and severe
which one do you think a little bit well
we could have a look at both I think
maybe I should I be editing this delight
do I need to update before I edit I
think it may be too soon to to go into
the details okay fine but just for
goodness sakes a represents a node in a
tree as opposed to just a node kind of
node you know um okay so there are some
random trees how do i how do I make a
just if I if I want to make so just if
I'm playing around with this um let's
say that I say Kaori tree using the
graph theory functionality right I say
Kari tree like 30 okay so that's gonna
make a carriage now how do I convert
that into this kind of tree I say graph
tree is that correct yes okay so that's
a little bit unfortunate can it not
sense the size properly yeah here it's
it's a default side that I've been using
so this will be updated to to have the
proper size by default by proper size
you may know size which depends on the
content yes but he's also something
that's I wanted to discuss we may have
some issue for very very large tree for
instance I don't know if you consider
come pre chemistry of 10 sorry I'm sorry
your word dropped out if you consider
what tree if you consider for instance
complete carry tree of 10 and you to a
graph tree on this will have difficulty
to represent the treatment object in the
end I think it would would be I mean
obviously there's a little bit of room
for things to resize based on content
but generally speaking that that is
weird and unusual behavior right and I
understand I understand I'm proposing I
mean we do it for images were
it's really really good behavior I think
this is a case where we should also do
it I know because the first of all
images have first of all images have
notion of the Natural Science and they
don't necessarily display at their
natural size either right but the point
is a four by four image for example does
not display as an invisible speck of
dust on your screen sure but you know I
think our knowledge of this is much less
than the knowledge we have of well I
think we also had a plan if I'm not
mistaken Roger maybe can confirm this
for graphs we are currently not resizing
graphs based on content is that correct
by default
mm right but but we are planning to do
so well moderately so but is what I see
why the killer in Italy there is no sirs
that contents wait a second what is a
better I'm glad I didn't I thought you
weren't gonna be here Charles I'm glad
you're here um the what are you saying
Charles I mean that clarity decisis bit
on the content but the current content
is based on the plot range of the
automatic so you're saying if I do a
carry tree of 200 no I mean the size
here as in the width is the same in both
cases if I do a canary tree of four or
something that's not very interesting
well but I see if you rely eventually on
the plot range but yes you are going
like Raja was pointing out we are going
to find a way to improve that right so
for example that carry tree graph would
by default look more like this except
that it would have its node sizes better
is that correct
sorry okay so we should do the same
whatever we're going to do there we
might as well do the same up to where we
can do it for the trees
okay let's also think for trees there is
a very easy way to we might not do this
in round one but I think we should
consider being able to collapse sub
trees cuz it's so obvious thing for
trees trees are so much simpler than
graphs yeah I agree
so you're proposing then that you could
click this node and it would collapse
right I think that would be wonderful
I mean do we have any comments on that
from I mean then we'd have to have entry
element we would have to have an option
that says whether it's open or closed
you also need another block
you know we mean another shape a box you
need to build another front-end box to
have that perform reasonably possibly
yes
okay whoo all right fine I think it's a
good idea though
Xavier you do you have comments on the
tree element design for that yes so the
main part I suppose that all of the
vertex should get their coordinates the
same or when we collapse any of the
branches oh that's an interesting
question Roger
if you collapsed this sub branch right
would you expect the three to be hanging
out there yes and and an indicator that
there is stuff underneath right but my
point is that this three has a lot of
extent over from the one right which it
actually doesn't need if everything
below it is collapsed yeah but I think
in the stew this is people complain
about this if you needlessly rerender
things because you can't visually know I
agree with you but but my question so
your point is I mean the problem I would
maintain its stable unless see if you
plot it from the beginning you know in a
visualization you say only visualize up
to level three or something like that
yeah but then it's gonna have everything
collapsed then it's gonna optimize at
that point well okay and then you're
saying it's gonna resize it re lay it
out yeah lower levels right but if you
interactively do it no I don't think it
should disrupt you know visually okay so
let me play that that let's not get down
this particular rathole for too long
here but I can see the issue with that
is let's say there were a thousand nodes
underneath three okay they're all
scrunched together down here unless you
know in other words if I keep opening
opening opening there's just like
thousands of nodes and they're not being
given any BRE this is why this is
probably not a first round project fine
okay because that will be almost as much
work as the rest of it fine okay all
right let's continue okay where should
we go next
Xavier was a Wes was the next
like the locker so something that we
keep wondering is the relation between
three-element and Bruce three so perhaps
if you open both pages trailer candies
and rules three because a second as a
constructor three element is kind of too
heavy and we find ourselves constructing
the trees always with really three which
is a lot simpler yes so to the point
that we now wonder which one is a proper
container so constructor
Bruce tree looks kind of more
interesting but as a container so that's
that's questions Revere has their ad yet
so the question is what is the canonical
form of the tree is that basically the
question yes yes should the canonical
form be I I have to say I my intuition
is that having something which has more
possibility for metadata and so on is a
better idea that trying to have too thin
a chemical form as a mistake I mean for
graphs we don't have a very thin
canonical form is that correct
they for a graph if I look at that graph
input form of of let's take a look here
now that's pretty ugly that's pretty
ugly I'm pretty unusable as an atomic
object you should efficiency expressions
expressions are not good models for many
things I know so this graph is created
from adjacency matrix so if it's you
know you can get there an equivalent
version if you get the set of holes so
you can have instead of null space or
you can have a set of holes to I'm sorry
so how do I get out from that
representation how do I get the thing
out as a set of rules in price but is
just edge list is what we provided to
user okay fine
so that's the equivalent then of tree
rules is that correct yes we have two
rules and Grocery know I understand it
so tree rules of percent true here is
that which is quite beautiful but really
doesn't contain you know doesn't have
any place to hang metadata right I mean
that's it that's a useful object there
and presumably if I say tree form of
that I'll get something which is a
decorated version of this right and if I
now say for this if I say rules tree
percent nine magnificent apart from the
overlapping craziness right so what's
wrong with this picture this seems
pretty good to me
it's not about the picture but the fact
that when when these scales to large
graphs the monolithic representation of
a single rules three or something like
that would be more efficient and a
nested theorem and again and again well
okay I can't comment on that I mean if
you're saying that if you're saying that
I mean like with graph that we want some
kind of atomic representation I kind of
don't agree with that I mean I think
look if there some more efficient
representation for the nested tree
element thing then there's all kinds of
caching possibilities and so on that I
can imagine for doing that but I'm not
clear what you're asking I mean is the
issue an efficiency problem with a
million tree tree elements or is the
issue something about the fact that it's
inconvenient to work with these nester
tree elements so what what do we say
yeah I think it's a bit of both if we
have a tree representation we may have
some faster manipulation of tree I think
in the end but it's not realistic it
doesn't have
a place to hang metadata so we can use a
so treatment could be used as well as
now actually to to have metadata for for
any node so you're proposing that the
canonical form that comes back from
something like a graph tree could be
some tree element thing so some of these
could be tree elements and some of them
could be rules is that your proposal yes
and then treatment will be used only to
add property to two nodes so somewhat
similar to what we're doing with graph
but exactly which property this no no
but the property thing is horrible so we
could we could see uh something maybe
you could see you know we zoo only woods
trees so this would be the kind
understand I don't understand why you
want to do this why I think it's a
mistake for this to be the canonical
representation because I don't think it
contains enough information and I think
the idea of mixing this with tree
elements seems wrong I mean I would just
figure out how to make the tree element
thing as efficient as possible and if we
really really really have to have
something where there's an opaque
version of some you know special fast
representation of a tree inside that
serializes is tree elements then so be
it
but I'm guessing the problem here which
is kind of similar to coffee coffee
I mean become like you suggested we can
put it caching and attach that a special
on for if you want to do first harvest
on our search you cannot go to that
necessary element it'd be inefficient
so we need a caching right more
efficient or presentation we use behind
the scene right that's what I'm saying
okay let's continue with this design
discussion I I'm not sold on changing I
I like the concept I mean let me just
understand if I were to look at percent
- if I say input form of percent - yeah
I mean I have no idea what the memory
footprint of this is but that can be
dealt with by various forms of caching
and so on but I think conceptually this
is pretty reasonable isn't it yes
conceptually it's flexible and follow
some of the things like XML element and
staged tournament I mean that input form
and can be computed you know if you have
another representation you call input
form it computes this form yeah might
not store that but it may compute it you
know on requests like that it also could
even happen that could be a post version
one feature that that's how it works you
know I think it would be nice - okay
in any case oh I think you know I think
we could get the trees out as an
experimental feature without having some
you know optimized internal
representation okay let's keep going
with it with this review here what's
this somebody's sending some chats a
thing you know just one show you - how
to change the size it's a prototype
version for the dream I don't want add a
single size that's the whole point
I want a size that yes yes yes with this
address - tuition if you want to change
them now just to make them like okay
let's let's take a look at this is that
the next thing to look at and yes this
is
there's a team so what is the poisons so
the first line our little post house
from Greece is Chris here no nothing
okay so please get him if we're gonna
talk this thing yeah okay let's look
back to something else okay so this is a
discussion we were just having and we
couldn't look at other pages yes please
and I want so have you implemented all
of the things that were for tree
traversal and - did we finish the design
of all the tree traversal tree
extraction you know uncle's
grandfather's piece of a tree type stuff
I think so from the point of view of
design where we have these three parts
which is quite flexible because it's
it's both a partial specification and
abstract specification and so can I see
that so let's see the so you have a tree
path page here in nothing but the ends
but give stacks from something tree
extracts yes okay so let me take my tree
here let's take um TTT as percent -
that's my tree so now let me kind look
at so if I say tree extract of let me
see if I can guess how to do this can I
say element 5 and can I say is that
going to be
tree well it's fine well here that
element named five how do I extract the
subtree of the element named five well
many elements could be named five so
this is how do I extract all of their
sub trees so this is extraction by
position like tree extract
okay so extract does is it is it by
positional by name so if I say this it
is disposition it has to be a position
that it exists if that is the left hand
side the one yes so this is one two but
this is in a tree path wrapper so this
is tripperz want what would want to mean
and without without the list without the
tree part I'm totally confused to us
this is why is this not one two so yes
this is one two but this is without the
least actually yes oh yes oh sure remove
this right parts back so the lists are
so lists are four just like of
multi-part things exactly so I could say
one two one come on there's a binary
tree I would say one two down there yeah
and that would make me two sub trees
exactly okay so now if I get down there
and then I say uncle's
so you don't have any uncles so it
shouldn't be specified within the tree
path what what's the third argument
oh those elements from the Association
okay so if I say here is to get the data
are the metadata of the nodes this
argument okay let me see if I understand
what on earth that did okay so one two
one one two yes the first part of the
tree path is the one element the two
elements so hands on the five right
there now go to that element and that
element okay so that yeah that's right
that's the parent and that's the uncle
right yeah so they both have
same uncle right okay so the idea is
that the second element of to extract
can also take a list which is a list of
triples and then each three paths can
specify lists which means sub lists okay
so how would I extract by name well
that's three cases three cases yes okay
do we have three cases oh no we don't
yes the main thing was to first check
how to implement at reportin because it
may be a bit difficult or non friendly
to specify a subtree that we want you to
extract well you're saying a tree
pattern that isn't just a single node
pattern right in other words if if what
we want you know it's a subtree based on
name yes the difficulty here is that if
we use if we could we could have a tree
katie's and use directly tree limb
anti-spartan but since it's going to
evaluate we will have to wrap this with
a whole pattern with what's going to
evaluate so it's really meant the
expression tree demand that we want to
use for three cases yeah why is that
kind of evaluate what doesn't three
elements and another object so it's
going to be passed to a canonical form
yeah so what so for instance if you do
treat a man brackets we say 1 comma
blank bracket you're saying ok ok let's
first of all let's look at what you've
got here okay
so first thing is let me just understand
so let's say this one here so it's a
flattened % 21
two identical things but let's say and
now I say tree expression just for fun
okay that seems wrong it should it
should be luster ball there okay yeah we
heard that yes okay wild but correct so
then if I say expression tree um
ah that works okay
okay so what other things so these are
conversion construction things yep
somebody's asking on the livestream will
this be integrated with other tree
related things such as text structure
and dendrogram how what does tender
ground actually return dendrogram
dendrogram returns a graphic right
standard a musical thing but what's the
thing underneath dendrogram it's a
clustering tree right and the clustering
tree so let's take a
what that does because that's the
underlying of this so let's say random
okay so there's our clustering tree
because that is that a graph and yes
okay so if I say graph tree very nice
except that we lost the labels we lost
the leaf labels yes so there is no
option query to to keep them it's yes
why isn't that to default so percent or
n6 okay so what do I do to keep those so
in a string this is treatment labels
like this
yes goes to what's what what are we
doing with an option on a string go on
but tell me what should be here go to
message no so this is oh yes this is
because they are using I see okay so
this is about you so here we keep them
but any to fix this looks kind of
horrifying so I think there are two
points here so clustering tree arguably
should return a tree I wouldn't make a
change well okay
we can worry about that I mean there's
there's but conceptually it should
return a tree maybe maybe not
what is it doing here I don't understand
that what did it do here so is that
badly rendered on top of each other or
something or what that is badly rendered
could somebody comment on that who's
who's coming here initially okay could
you could you deal with that that's
obviously really awful documentation
example I mean if they actually two
problems here one is these things should
be resized down to thumbnail size when
they're put in here but and second of
all okay but but then the question
whether this is a tree or whether it is
a graph
that has to be converted to a tree is a
separate question but um the other thing
is when we do have a graph the we do
have a graph the the question of how we
move over graph annotation I mean
presumably if I have a graph that isn't
a tree and I say graph tree it'll just
say forget it you've got something that
isn't I mean if I say complete graph of
4 or something like this ok now I say
graph tree it just says forget it oh
come on that's a you know our general
principle for error is not to say should
be anything it's just is not and this is
a very awkward to say it it's not a tree
just say it's not a tree and don't say
argument 1 just say bla bla bla is not a
tree reason for sure we're okay there we
change this but but that's a general
principle of our messages to simply say
what we know don't say what it you know
what it ought to be so to speak okay
from our live stream we have a comment
that guessing that the su is that
dendrogram has much more going on EG
branch weights than a conventional
abstract tree that's an interesting
point um I don't know how the weights
are represented here does somebody know
um and in fact is it the case
I mean that's the whole point of our
tree element structure is that we can
put weights into the tree element
structure correct yes we're gonna add
those later right which is why it's
really nice to have that you know
metadata capable symbolic expression so
comment from Michael Hale here says he's
writing a community post on visualizing
the amount of GenBank sequence data
available for related species sub trees
right now great I've interested to see
it the UM I'm kind of hoping that I
would I would hope that some of our
clustering tree functionality would be
relevant for that but yes this is some
okay another question here is there an
implementation of suffix trees what
would that mean exactly I mean we have a
certain we have a thing that's actually
getting much okay here's a question for
you guys so we have autocomplete right
let's imagine that we have from you know
random word let's say we have 30 random
words here okay and now we say
autocomplete with that that makes an
auto completion function and if we say
auto completion function of B let's
think this will make there we go
that now I think this is making a suffix
tree so that is conceptually internally
a suffix tree is it not Roger
somebody I don't know how this is
implemented well I know how this is it
be it should be but I mean conceptually
we use suffix tree for kinds of things
but but I'm not an implicit question
here is should we be exposing a suffix
tree
what would a suffix tree look like in
our tree formalism and then how would
you use a suffix tree if it was
represented in a tree formalism you get
what I'm saying that might be a cool
application example to think about you
know let's think about how that would
work I mean in other words okay let's do
as an exercise let's create a suffix
tree okay how would we do that
so we want to go from here
right yes tell me how to create the
suffix tree maybe maybe I can make a
more trivial suffix tree with just two
poles or something I guess we will have
to separate characters and then doing
some sort of nested together by but
there's some combination all right let's
take this as an example
all right this should be easier to make
a suffix tree out of all right so what's
gonna happen then is every what's gonna
happen here it's gonna be gathering from
the first element and then mapping the
gather how does this work gather by
first for something is that right
hey we've got background noise could
somebody make sure they're muted right
but we
than saying what to gather what to
gather element
look this seems like a good exercise to
make a suffix tree and then the question
is once we have that suffix tree how
would we use it Trey Trey guru by first
arrow crest I looks lovely okay and then
you're gonna tell me
to go now I guess we have to do fold
fold though I would love nest to get
angry okay
we don't mind but the next level the
same thing oh that's not right right
because we have to we have we really
have to go and um well okay here let's
just get two levels of the suffix tree
okay so for this we'd go map um group by
hash first our arrest okay right now let
me turn this into a tree how do I turn
this into a tree actually I'm just gonna
just for fun I'm gonna go one more level
okay mm-hmm so I want to do this correct
yes okay all right now how do I turn
that into a tree I mean actually we need
to value something we need to who's
normal okay maybe we shouldn't need
normal but yeah okay so we need a nested
normal right yes um kind of fun I see so
so brony we needed to wrap normal around
the loop ice well I mean we could just
map all normal here okay okay
so now now this is a rules tree right so
now what I want to say is rules tree of
that yes yes so that we have a list at
the answers let see what happens now
that is not encouraging
mmm-hmm why is the rule why is that list
at the end causing trouble I don't think
it should do it's being green but let's
let's just for the sake of having
something work let's put an F for round
that list at the end okay so it's level
minus two minus three so I think when
you show you that we don't have a root
here
oh yes that yeah okay explain that so
how would we make I see so there's two
elements at the top level right yes so
what should we do in that case with the
rules tree with two elements at the top
level oh maybe you can just add what
should we do I think this should make
two disjoint tree tree pieces what did
what do to Roger and Charles have an
opinion about that
Roger sorry I also mute again yes we
were wondering whether who's three of a
list will do a single tree or several
trees why can't a single tree because
they're not connected to a root yeah but
we could introduce some sort of
fictitious root like we do he goes now
goes to that list well if you have two
or twice I mean do they constitute two
disconnected tree or not if the
disconnected tree should be two
different ways yeah but we don't know I
mean this is the case we're trying to
build a suffix tree here and the suffix
tree has no I mean this would be I don't
know in the if it was the other way
around this would be an epsilon or
something in the world of transducers or
something that would be some sort of
what would Roger what would this be in
the world of transducers how would you
start this thing yes you could you could
have an epsilon transition into both yes
I don't know if this is the only what's
the most useful behavior for it to have
is it not useful to have one tree or
multiple truck let's try with two trees
okay so in this case what I could do
here I could say map
rules tree over this right yes and you
replace the F by flooding
um why just to some sense have something
cleaner in using boot okay fair enough
but I don't see what this does
okay fine so it's a little bit yeah okay
I get it um who you try again there were
three of a bracket percent forty forty
five each work actually so now it's
should already have some thread on the
first argument okay but so I think it
should make a forest I'm not joking
right seriously because in all the
serious pre-application the mathematical
what's not the ones that are trusts for
display like for partial differential
equations indication of money faults
what always wants to keep who is to
guess all nicely suture you mean tree
should represent forests or do you mean
a list of trees now I meant we should
have a symbolist okay which is attaining
at home yes okay so this raises the
question which we haven't even touched
on of machine learning you know decision
trees and things has anybody looked at
whether these map onto the stuff that we
have for decision trees and machine
learning system and or random forests so
we should look at that net en would know
about that okay but but but let's take
this example for a you know this is
trying to be a suffix tree how will we
use the suffix tree so we would
presumably use a tree extract the suffix
tree is presumably a tree extract of
let's say let's just do the first one
here so notice that we have mess on our
hands because the tree extract we would
like there to be a root here if we're
gonna use tree extract on the thing if
there was a root now we've got to do
this tree path which I'm not sure I
totally like anymore and again we can't
do tree path by name we're doing tree
path by this is a mess guys we're doing
tree path by position whereas we really
want for the suffix tree to do tree path
by name so that seems to be a thing
that's coming up a fair bit is then
what's the tree by name go ahead I think
we need both things like we need extract
and engages in in general you have a
tree this isn't quite tree cases because
this is walk the tree but in every node
decide which side you're going based on
the name of the node not on the part
number of the node yes yes we so we need
we need both and actually team path
should even be able to do cases as it
goes down okay well how I mean yes
that's what I think too
I think it should be able to go either
by position either by part number or by
name possibly all by other metadata I'm
not sure I don't see how to specify that
so here it's working with Casey's the
Casey's aperture so tree price bracket
Casey's brackets and the portal
for three demons what what are you
saying so if I want this to go down go
ahead you can do trip as blackcats
K Z's procured so here this is this is
get complicated because we don't have a
trip our channel so this will be whole
pattern instead of one what what what
what what what hi this is gonna get way
too complicated yes right we lost this
game so but but what we need to do here
is assume that the names are unique I
wish they might not be in different
cases if they're not but assume they've
been correctly the tree has been set up
as a uniquely named tree hmm possibly
something that there should be a queue
function that tests for what would that
what would the mathematical name for a
tree with unique names be
that's not really a mathematical concept
right that's like uniquely labeled hue
or something yeah right well okay but
but so in that case this is almost like
a tree name part right that looks at the
names rather than that you know it's
almost like there's a tree part path and
a tree name part making sense I'm not
sure
so the our plan was to have some sort of
query ability at each level so it's time
that you go one level deeper or a burn
into path we wanted to put here a form
of query that would take cases in a
particular case just that we have
focused on the positional aspects so far
right I think we're gonna want a name
thing I think it's gonna be useful for
many purposes just a simple thing where
you can say extract the you know walk
down the tree extracting such in such an
element for example the suffix tree case
is an example of that by the way I also
think we probably actually have function
to make a suffix tree which is what is
internally happening in this case it's
also totally happening in genome lookup
and a bunch of other things I'm making
sense
hello is there's no reason we can't have
something that creates a suffix tree
from a list of objects a list of Lists
that makes sense I think we can have
many constructors and and that would be
one right here I'm saying that's what
making it rich if you have a no I agree
but okay so we agree we're gonna have a
suffix tree constructor um okay somebody
is asking on the live stream about a
tree option represents family trees as
in genetic Matic magic means but what
does it mean we're a single individual
has two parents or more yes yes yes what
how do we deal with that how do we even
think about that
we don't in this in this construction
yes but if we if we were to generalize
our trees so for example in the wolf
malphur world you know if I say um you
know if I say uncles uncles grandmother
I'm getting that what is this from a
tree point of view is it a tree or is it
not a its I mean that's a fragment of a
tree right there's an infinite tree so
to speak or of a tree with a hundred
billion nodes for all the humans who
have ever lived right and and you get I
mean with with the human case you get
like these hourglass diagrams right
where there's you in the middle and
there's um how do those trees relate is
it is the hourglass diagram well it's
not
three did I mean it would be directed
acyclic graph but you know which is then
as our concept is this order to
orientate kruta trees and and this is if
we take the notes to be a couple's or
individuals then this will be like two
of those trees one oriented upwards and
then the other one downwards
well it that's the case where you're in
the middle right well you have
descendants and you have ancestors right
but I think there are like three or four
different standard views of a
genealogical tree which as you point out
it's not really a tree there are several
concepts and we are using our restricted
concept is ordered oriented good it fair
enough okay another person is suggesting
collapsible tree they're showing an
example here of a collapsible tree yeah
well right this is this is what we're
talking about with them I don't know how
this is working but victim yeah now
notice that this one does move as you
don't think we were talking about before
whether the thing moves as you open a
node but notice how they have this sort
of incremental animations going on there
too to help visually so you don't get
this you know um yeah I mean that kind
of mechanism is certainly a type of tree
visualization that we would like to have
and that's I mean that goes along the
lines of what we were discussing earlier
with these trees with openers all right
let's let's go back here - lets
what else do we need to achieve in this
meeting have we been making I mean we're
I would like to go through some other
actual use cases here but um
go ahead trivia what what else do you
want to make sure we achieve here but
I'm just warning you I have a meeting
with external people in yes so Chris
joined so maybe we can even go back I
can choose if I'm sitting okay okay so
what so what is this now why are we
using these nasty Brown this is me from
from the copy-pasting I think it's much
clearer on the web no no but I
understand what that color is our old
graph plot color which I was don't think
worked out that well I think I must have
pulled that color incorrectly from a
prior versions of documentation and
looking at what we've been looking at on
the screen today I will bring it back to
our current blue-gray style okay but so
what is this what is this a picture of
what is what are you listening yeah this
was and this was as I was trying to
tackle this besides just a little bit of
the actual visual styling I was looking
at what we do with I'm sorry I've lost
resume fire file here trees nested
within a tree if you have saying you're
a root node here we can have children
off that but in the sample notebook that
I have we have you can have sort of
elements nested within this parent
element so I was initially playing
around without really thinking and do a
lot of consideration to technical
constraints of can we have an an opener
or an ellipsis to show so that that's
not where we're at right now so that
that's cool for the future but that's
not where we're at right now what we
trying to solve what what thing do we
think is not working in this
visualization here which looks quite
reasonable to me
I now that I look at it again and now
that I'm doing another review of
documentation visually I think it's
pretty much in line with the new styles
that we are using however thinks I mean
I don't know whether we like yellow is
the color as the theming color for these
things but doesn't seem obviously wrong
mm-hmm okay so does anybody so if I were
to have a node here that has no label um
your that would how would that display
right now can I see one of those severe
is there an easy way to make a tree with
it without a label there let's see maybe
worse to be a goes to B comma C like
this and come out like saying this
should be vertex labels goes to and here
I think I'm using another for this
prototype I'm not sure
no so it all no I don't think we can do
it in any zoo then it's a way but it's
not a sorry okay so in general here but
yeah I might be able to actually find
the sample code that I was going from
two bases off of what what did we have
so if I do a rules 3a % 9 with vertex
labels to none would I get some other
behavior here yeah okay looks quite
beautiful okay anybody have a problem
with this it looks looks okay to me and
I'm not totally certain about the shade
of yellow and things but it looks I mean
the the geometry looks pretty good to me
Roger Charles Michael anybody
think we should go with yellow what
would be your favorite color I don't
know but I yellow fields very very you
know two three versions ago it'd be a
bit boring but we could simply go with a
very light gray in the background or
pure white but that's not even white
work yeah it needs an evil of something
what well what what places could we
imagine taking the palette for this from
and the other thing it's probably needs
a theme doesn't it
thought theme so you can't was a few
standard things and then you can have
something that's more sort of energetic
visually active and something that's
just more everyday right the question is
what should the everyday one be what
what would be the wet where could we
draw the palette for this from I mean in
graph we are and graph what are the
nodes look like in graph there bluish
aren't they I think so yeah
yeah but now if I label a node here so
if I say can I do this vertex labels are
automatic yeah okay so we
where we're labeling the nodes for a
graph we're labeling external to the
node how can I put those labels inside
the nodes placed Center how do I do it
your place automatic by place in code
name comma Center name yes got to
specify the actual label what's really
isn't me okay that's pretty ugly so I
mean that would be the natural palette
to use here mm-hmm
do we want and again for the edges don't
we want the edges for the tree to agree
with the edges for the graph by default
guys I think it's important that you
something that visually indicates it's
not a graph you know because otherwise
you kind of and I think that the more of
these things we do the more you need
some we need to come up with some more
little bit you know this is that close
but not the same visual cues that tells
you what object would kind of think that
you can expect to do with it so here you
see around it the frame around it has a
different color when it's a graph no
they're both purple well but that means
it's a graph yes in this case we are
using a graph saying it's purple as
opposed to orange for the forum in the
case of ordinary graphic over which is
have a different shape what the
mouse-over shape I mean the to do the
mouse appearance you see the mouse has
an edge on it yeah well do you both
graphs well you know they both cough so
if I if I just do a graphics circle or
something you're saying the mouse has an
arrow in that case or something yeah you
know I never noticed I did notice that
there was different I couldn't figure
out what that thing was
what is that that's a little edge that's
the icon for i'ma graph what's that
yes an edge okay but but your point is
what I think that you know there's been
fairly muted at this point but if we're
gonna have more objects that are
visually very close to each other but
not the same I think we're gonna have to
become a little bit more in-your-face
you know that you that you know are you
sure I mean the expressions that are
aren't the same but well she's not quite
correct
um I mean there certainly are
indications that we give in different
places of things being different which I
think have worked out fairly well in
this case what does what does Michael
think do you have an idea Michaels
disappear okay well so
we've solved this problem of what the
visual look should be I think what what
Revere has right now is certainly not
terrible
I think you know the palate has to
somehow agree or disagree with graphs I
think it's super unfortunate what
happens when the labels are placed as
they are there with graph if I say
vertex style arrows something or other
can I get that - um yeah I mean it's
still kind of ugly because I don't have
the things large enough how would I how
would I specify the margin it's that
excise goes to medium how did that also
they put them at a specific number
that's here that maybe ten five what
another four the unit's here that's
quite beautiful that's beautiful be nice
if that was easier to do I mean you know
it wasn't it wasn't labeled centric I
think that we can do you know going
forward their various visual tricks like
using scrims is an important aspect
actually placing them in a more adaptive
fashion there okay I've got a very
simple suggestion just like you have a
named you know vertex labels are
automatic vertex labels arrow name let's
have a string name that produces vertex
labels inside the vertices okay I mean
there
big you know they won't fit I understand
so then it won't work but but if they do
fit then give people a way to easily ask
for them so I mean it would be something
like well name in place that's not right
the right terminology um but you get
what I'm saying that some annotation to
the word name hmm because this is very
nice what it did here very nice
um okay all right
does Revere need anything else right now
and by the way I don't think we need to
kill these meetings
um well Jose is away um it's great foes
a to be here but I don't think it's
absolutely essential
um and I'd like to continue them so that
we can actually you know hit our targets
with this for version 12 okay and
anything else for this meeting thanks to
folks on the livestream number of very
useful comments today thank you and
thanks to already in the meeting and
have a good trip Jose thank you see you
later guys